what a tremendous absolute waste of time
for everybody who watches this this is
not a hearing it's a human resources
okay anybody who has been on both sides
of the coin right either you have been
in charge of a project or an incoming
boss understands what you are seeing it
works like this you're in charge of a
department a new boss comes in he needs
to establish a new way his stamp your
priorities don't jive there is a tug of
war between sides the boss always wins
here's the great news about this the
priorities that the person leaving often
remain the custodian is gone but the
struggle is necessary for the two to
prove the viability of the existing
structure right people they say we need
this for the Ukraine Trump's like I
don't know so it comes together this is
not impeachment this is what happens in
the office the irony is the people who
work for a living
aren't here to watch this to laugh at
this the media thinks this is important
because they've never been in a
workplace situation they've never
managed anything they've never been an
incoming boss so they're pricked into
thinking this is something important
when this is something that happens
every single day and everyone's business
it's a freaking joke sorry how do you
really feel great